TIMOTHY JORDAN: So this is
a talk about Glass--
in specific, building new
experiences for Glass.
I'm Timothy Jordan--
that's me.
Hi.
I'm a developer advocate
at Google on Glass.
If you want to get in touch
online after this, go ahead
and check out
google.com/+timothyjordan.
So what are we going to
talk about today?
Project Glass, of course, which
is part of Google X, the
moonshot factory at Google.
Moonshots are these radical
ideas for changing the world
and improving the way
that we live.
For more on Google X and
moonshots, you really should
check out Astro's
talk tomorrow.
He'll be here in
the afternoon.
This particular moonshot,
Project Glass, is about our
relationship to technology.
It's about technology that's
there when you want it but out
of the way when you don't.
What do I mean by that?
Last night I went
to this event.
How many of us went to
parties last night?
Just a few?
OK, everyone.
So as people were taking
the stage,
this weird thing happened.
And it happens at South By,
but it happens at other
places, too-- all of these
screens went up into the air.
Tablets and phones--
all of these things mediating
these people's experience with
what was in front of them.
It's weird because it felt like
they were watching the
screens instead of the event.
I mean, we all love technology
and what it can give us-- the
ability to take and
share pictures--
but it feels like tech is often
getting in the way more
than it needs to.
And that's what we're addressing
with Project Glass.
It's so that you can still have
access to the technology
that you love but it doesn't
take you out of the moment.
I'm going to play a video.
Many of you have already seen
this video, but I want to play
it because I love it.
But also, it's really good at
showing you what it's like to
wear Glass.
Oops, I think I need to hook
in a cable for the video.
OK, that'll take
just a second.
How is everyone?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Do you see anything
with those glasses right now?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I will answer
those questions in a moment.
Why don't I tell you a joke?
This is a joke that I've been
thinking about a lot lately
because we've been
doing demos.
You want to hear it?
It's a computer science joke.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
So a mechanical engineer, an
electrical engineer, and a
computer scientist are riding
along in a car and the car
starts making this really
funny noise.
And the mechanical engineer's
like, well, why
don't we pull over?
I'm going to pop the hood and
hit it with a big old hammer.
The electrical engineer says,
that's kind of crazy.
How about we pull over and
I'll hook up my computer.
We'll see what code it's
giving and we'll
know what to do then.
The computer scientist
says, oh, all that is
just so much work.
We're going to stop the car,
turn it off, get out, get back
in, turn it on, and see if it's
still making the noise.
[LAUGHTER]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
I think we have audio.
[WIND BLOWING]
[FLAMES WHOOSHING]
[ROCK MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: OK, Glass,
record a video.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is it.
We're on in two minutes.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, Glass.
Hang out with the flying club.
MALE SPEAKER: Google photos
of tiger heads.
Hmm.
MALE SPEAKER: You ready?
You ready?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Right there.
OK, Glass.
Take a picture.
CHILD: I got it!
[ROCK MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Go!
Woohoo!
MALE SPEAKER: Being
upside down.
MALE SPEAKER: Holy [BLEEP].
That is awesome.
CHILD: Whoa, look
at that snake!
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK, Glass,
record a video!
Whooo!
[SCREAMING]
MALE SPEAKER: After this
bridge, first exit.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: Kelly!
Up!
[ROCK MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: OK, 812,
right there.
[ROCK MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Celebrate!
FEMALE SPEAKER: Wow.
MALE SPEAKER: Google, say
delicious in Thai.
GOOGLE GLASS:
[FOREIGN LANGUAGE].
MALE SPEAKER: Mm, [INAUDIBLE].
FEMALE SPEAKER: Google
jellyfish.
MALE SPEAKER: Ha.
Oh, let's see.
It's beautiful.
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You can clap.
It's OK.
So this is the idea, that by
bringing technology closer we
can get it more out
of the way.
It seems a little ironic and
it's a bit of a crazy idea but
that's why it's a moonshot.
All right.
So let me frame this talk
just a little bit.
For more information on the
product, Glass, go to
google.com/glass.
We've got a bunch of information
up there.
Today, I'm going to be talking
to developers, those
interested in building new
experiences for Glass.
So for the rest of this session,
I'm going to be
talking about APIs and
building with Glass.
And you might ask, why are we
doing this now, because we're
not selling Glass and we're not
releasing any APIs today.
In fact, I should let you
know-- we're not done.
It's early days yet, and some
things that you see today
could change before we
release the API.
But we're here because at
South by Southwest, it's
filled with builders and
visionaries and thinkers and
the conversation that you have
out in the public is an
inspiration to us as we continue
to work on Glass.
So we want your feedback and
we want to kickstart the
conversation with some more
information about how these
APIs are going to work.
Does that sound like fun?
AUDIENCE: Woo!
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
Let me talk a little bit more
about that conversation,
because I think this is
a really key point.
So at Google I/O last year, we
had people sign up for what we
called the Explorer program
and it was a chance to get
early access to Glass.
As they came up and they signed
up, we gave them a
glass bar, something that looked
a little bit like this.
And I was so excited.
They gave me one, too.
This is mine and I'm
number 2182.
It's a high number, I know.
I went home and I took a photo
of this glass bar and I put it
on Google+.
I posted it to all my friends.
I posted it publicly so that
everybody could see how
excited I was.
And it was interesting.
This weird thing happened right
after that-- we started
seeing a whole bunch of these
photos go up, and people were
doing this crazy thing.
They weren't just taking a photo
of the bar or talking
about the Explorer program--
they put the bar out there where
they live and took a
photo, or in front of the people
that they love, or in
front of things that they care
about, or the places that made
them feel home.
And it was then that we started
to figure out that
this was more than just
a group of people
signing up for a device.
It was a bunch of people
that wanted
to be part of something.
OK.
This is going to be kind of
crazy, but I'm going to ask
you a few questions.
Maybe the people up here and
I'll repeat you say.
Why did you come to this
session today?
AUDIENCE: I knew about the
technology and I wanted to see
it in person.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You wanted
to see the technology.
What else?
Anyone, just shout it out.
AUDIENCE: Wondering how it's
going to change UX.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Wondering how
it's going to change user
experience.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Learn something new
we don't already know about.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Learn something
new that you don't
already know about.
Yeah, what else?
AUDIENCE: Wanted to be
on your spank bank.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I don't know
what that means, so I'm not
going to repeat it.
Over here?
AUDIENCE: Get to try
Google Glass.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You won't get
to try Google Glass today.
Come on, seriously--
what else?
AUDIENCE: Because this is
the next thing, right?
We're going from-- technology
is getting closer
and closer to us.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Technology is
getting closer and closer to
us and this is the next thing.
It's where things are going.
Do something great.
Now the thing is that I have
this conversation a lot, and
there's a couple new
things today.
Again, I don't know what
you said, but I--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: He wants to
be close to you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
There's a few things that come
up time and time again.
How is this going to
change the user
experience and what's next?
People keep talking about the
future of technology.
And that's the thing is that
we as a group, we're the
pioneers that get to decide how
this fits into our lives.
And with your help,
we can do that.
This is about a conversation of
all of us together thinking
about this new generation of
technology, thinking about
something that doesn't
compete with but
blends into your life.
After all, this is the future
that we're talking about, and
that's where we're going to
start, that one big theme,
that we're building new
paradigms for how technology
and information works
for people.
So let's start there.
These are the four things
that we're going
to talk about today.
I'm going to give you a demo.
That's exciting, no?
OK.
It's exciting for me.
I'm going to show you a demo
and I'm going to give you a
quick look at the Glass
UI live onstage.
We're going to look at the
Google Mirror API.
I'm going to give you a sneak
peek of what's going to be
available to developers.
It's not everything, but
a quick overview.
And then we're going to go
through some guidelines.
These are things that we've
learned developing with Glass
over the last many,
many months.
And these rules are going to
help us all sort of navigate
this new technology.
And then finally, I'm going to
go through some great examples
of new experiences that
we've been building
with some of our friends.
Sound like fun?
AUDIENCE: Whoo!
TIMOTHY JORDAN: [CHUCKLE]
There's so many of you.
OK, demo.
Now, this is going to
be interesting.
I was talking with the
folks back home--
I really wanted to show y'all
what it was like, what I was
seeing on Glass specifically.
To experience Glass, you really
need to put it on but
I'm going to give you an
overview and do my best to
give you the feeling
live today.
To do it, we had to
do some hacking.
I've got a cable connected to
this demo device, the specific
device I'll be using for demos,
and it's going to
transit my screen through
the laptop and on there.
It's going to be a little bit
more choppy and it's going to
be a little delayed.
It's way more swift and smooth
actually on Glass.
But the team wouldn't let me
bring 1,000 to Texas, so this
is what we've got to do.
All right.
Let me set this up.
I don't know what's
going to happen.
Hopefully it'll be fun.
Ooh.
OK, I think it's
going to work.
All right.
So first off, when I put on
Glass, notice that it's not in
my line of sight.
That's really key.
Now, you've probably seen a
few people walking around
South By wearing Glass.
And you'll notice that none
of them have it right in
front of their eye.
And that's really important
because as I'm wearing Glass,
I still want to be able to
connect with you and make eye
contact, and I also don't
want anything in the
way of what I'm doing.
But we want Glass in our field
of vision, so all I have to do
is look up quickly and
there's the screen.
So on the side here,
as you may have
guessed, is a touch pad.
I'm going to go ahead and tap on
that and it's going to take
me to the home screen.
If I go ahead and slide
down, it'll dismiss--
kind of like the back button
on your Android phone.
And it can also hear me.
OK, Glass, Google, how do you
say thank you in Japanese?
Oh, arigato.
So you'll see that--
you can clap as much
as you want.
It's totally fine.
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So that was
a live Google search right
there, and it gave me a
result on the screen
that I could see.
And it also said to me how
to pronounce arigato.
You didn't hear it because that
was audio just for me.
You notice I don't have anything
in my ear so I still
hear all the ambient audio
around me, but I can also hear
something from Glass.
All right.
Do you mind if I
take a picture?
AUDIENCE: Go for it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK, so
we'll do this one.
OK, Glass, take a picture.
Hey, there we are.
So you'll notice I can turn
Glass on by looking
up like I just did.
And if I want, I can scroll
to that photo.
And if I do a quick, hey, how
you doing, it'll nudge the
screen to dismiss it.
So with these input options--
voice, touch on the side, and
some basic head gestures--
I can control Glass in just
about any situation.
Let's do a couple more things.
So I'm going to go to that
picture I just took.
I'm here at the home screen.
I'm going to slide forward.
There's that picture--
don't you all look wonderful?
I'm going to tap right
on that picture,
and I get card options.
Now, this picture is
a timeline card.
And on there, when I tap, I
can get options, including
Share and Delete.
I'm going to choose Share and
I'm going to share it with my
friends on Google+.
Done.
These timeline cards, there's
a bunch of them.
Sidney's taking some photos--
I'm getting some updates
from him.
You'll notice that I
have his picture,
I've got the arigato--
these are things that have
happened in time.
We're going backward in time
as I swipe forward.
If I swipe backward, we go
forward in time, or to the
left, and I can swipe all
the way over here to
some Google Now cards.
You can see that I've
got the weather and
I've got some places.
Now a note about this
special card.
You'll notice it has a fold
in the upper right.
If I tap on a card like this,
it expands into more items.
In this case, it's the
three day forecast.
If I swipe down, I'll kind
of back out of that.
This is what we call a bundle.
All right.
Now I think there's enough
terminology for now.
We've got the timeline, swipe
forward to go back in time,
swipe the other way to
go to things that are
happening right now.
At any moment I can swipe
down and tap and
I'm at the home screen.
Does that all make sense?
Super simple, right?
All right.
We're going to come back
to this, I promise.
We're going to do more.
But first, let's talk through
a few more things.
Let's talk about the
Google Mirror API.
This is the first time that
we're talking about the Google
Mirror API, and I have to say
I'm really excited to actually
start talking about this
in the public.
We built the Google Mirror API
so people could build Glass
services quickly and easily.
It's not complex.
This is my fancy diagram.
It's got three things on it.
The only important thing for
this talk is this section over
here, because that's all
you have to build for.
The Google Mirror API is a cloud
API and it works with
RESTful Services, OAuth2,
and we transport the
data through JSON.
So a quick few questions
for you.
We're going to know pretty
quickly how many engineers we
have in the audience.
Who is familiar with OAuth2?
Ooh, a lot of you--
that's great.
Who is familiar with REST?
Also a lot of you.
And of course, JSON.
More.
Yes, OK.
So for those of you that didn't
raise your hand, let me
go through each of these
very quickly.
Now, they're open standards,
they're all available on the
web, with much more information
than I can explain
right here.
But let me, again, just give you
a quick overview of each
so that you'll know
what I'm talking
about as we move forward.
So first off, REST is
a web architecture.
It's essentially a mechanism for
transporting data between
two surfaces using HTTP, or
the protocol of the web.
It typically works with
resources or collections of
things that you can insert,
update, delete, and list.
And you use HTTP methods
for that.
You can use POST to insert, you
can use PUT to update, you
can use DELETE to delete, and
you can use GET to list all of
the items or any one item
in a collection.
Does that make sense?
OAuth2 has sometimes been
referred to as the valet keys
for the internet.
It's a way to allow a third
party service to do things on
your behalf.
In this case, if I want to
install a service for Glass, I
give it permission through
OAuth2 to write
things to my timeline.
Again, really simple, right?
You can think of that
as the install
process for Glass services.
And finally, JSON, or JavaScript
Object Notation, is
just an encapsulation.
We did XML for a long time as
a community, but now JSON's
really the thing.
And it all centers around these
timeline cards, so let's
start there.
The timeline card is just a
discreet bit of data that you
send to Google and then
Google syncs to the
user's Glass for you.
Now remember that diagram--
all that syncing and knowing
whether the device is online
or offline, that's all done for
you by Google, up to and
including how to display these
things on Glass and actually
rendering that UI.
Now these timeline cards can be
text, images, rich HTML, it
can be video.
And it can also be bundles
of things.
Remember, we saw this with
the weather card.
Whenever you see that fold in
the upper right hand corner
and you tap on it, it'll
expand into sort of a
subtimeline, if you will,
and you can see
multiple items there.
And that's really great for
Glass, because you can kind of
have a very efficient timeline
but then you can drill deeper.
Now this is what it looks
like in code.
And it could be just as simple
as this, is you've got a text
variable set to "Hello world,"
you send that to Google, and
we push a timeline card to the
user that says "Hello world."
You can insert images this way
using a multipart request, and
you can insert rich
HTML as well.
Now these items can be by
themselves or you can do
bundling, and there's two
ways to do bundling.
The first way is through
something that's kind of like
pagination.
It's a single card that you
insert into the timeline
collection that includes
an HTML cover
card and HTML pages.
Those are the multiple pages
that you tap into.
This is really great if you
have sort of a single item
that you want to represent
in more than one screen.
And it could also be multiple
timeline cards that are all
linked together with
a bundle ID.
So you just set a common bundle
ID across multiple
cards that you insert and we'll
put them together in a
single bundle.
If you want to do an update,
just do a PUT request.
You'll notice on the endpoint
there I'm also specifying the
item's ID at the end
of timeline.
And I'm just going to update
that again to hello world,
this time without an
exclamation mark.
You can do delete--
this is a DELETE request.
And of course, you can list any
single item or the whole
list of items.
So those are cards.
You can insert them, they can
be lots of different types.
There's also these
card options.
Now remember, I tapped
on that picture and I
got Share and Delete.
Well, you can specify that
menu when you insert a
timeline card and it's
really easy to do.
There's two types of
these timeline card
options, if you will.
There's Reply and there's
Read Aloud.
Those are system options.
You can also do custom options,
which are whatever
you specify.
They have your display name,
your icon, and they do what
you want them to do.
To insert system options, all
you have to do is name them.
So you can see we're back to
this timeline card insertion,
and we're specifying in the JSON
hello world, and I'm also
specifying an array
of card options.
And the one that I specify, I'm
just naming it Read Aloud,
and that will add Read Aloud
to this timeline card.
If I want a custom option, I've
got to specify just a few
more things.
You'll see the action here
is custom, but then I'm
specifying an ID, a display
name, and an icon URL--
in this case, love, as if you
were to love an item on a
service, because we're
in Austin.
No?
Come on, so much love
around here.
We've got some share entities.
Remember when I tapped on that
picture and then I tapped on
Share and I got my Google+
Circle for friends?
Well, Google+ is a Glass
service using the API.
It added that share
entity for me.
Any Glass service out there can
add their own set of share
entities so that when I take a
picture or a video on Glass, I
can send it to any one
of those services.
To insert a share entity,
it's a POST request.
But this time it's on the
share entities endpoint
instead of the timeline
endpoint, right?
So we're just sending this
to a different URL.
And I'm specifying an ID, a
display name, and an image to
show along with that.
OK, subscriptions.
So this is the last big thing.
For subscriptions, this is
important for your card
options and your share entities,
because what the
user is going to do is they're
going to perform an action,
Glass will tell Google, and then
Google will notify your
Glass service, and it
happens real quick.
To do that, you first need to
subscribe to the timeline
collection or whatever
collection we make available.
And you specify your
subscription this way, by
doing, again, a POST request,
using the RESTful protocol to
say, hey, I want
a subscription.
Here's the user token or the
verify token to repeat back to
me so I know what you're talking
about, and here's a
callback URL.
This is where I want you
to send the data.
And then what Google's going to
do is every time it gets a
user action, it's going
to send you a
lightweight ping in JSON.
It's going to include things
like the timeline ID.
So in the case of a picture,
you'll get that timeline ID
and then you'll do a GET request
on the timeline like
we saw earlier and download
the photo.
Does that make sense?
All right.
The lightweight ping's
going to look a
little bit like this.
OK.
So that was a mouthful,
mostly, for me.
It was a lot of technical stuff
about how the API works.
And it's really important
because these are sort of the
major building blocks for
creating Glass services.
I'm going to go through
them one more time.
You have the timeline cards, and
these are things that you
can insert for the user and
they'll see them on Glass.
Those cards can have options
and those options can be
system options, like Reply or
Read Aloud, and we'll see
those in a demo in a moment, or
they can be custom options,
in which case you specify what
it's called and what the icon
is and then you handle
that for the user.
The share entities--
and these get added to the
share menu for any media
created on Glass like pictures
and like videos.
And then finally,
subscriptions.
By subscribing to updates to the
timeline, you get notified
with lightweight JSON pings
whether the user hits a card
option or if they hit
a share entity.
All make sense?
OK.
Next up, guidelines.
So this is really key because
it's a new platform.
It's a new form of technology,
so we need some new
rules for the road.
We've done a lot of thinking and
playing and experimenting
and here's just four quick
things that we found make a
Glass service really great.
First, design for Glass.
Glass is a unique platform
that's mobile, but it's
fundamentally different than
existing platforms like your
phone or your tablet.
And you want to build for Glass
with this in mind, that
it's for Glass.
You wouldn't want to take an
experience somewhere else and
just stamp it out for Glass.
And you'd also want to take the
time to experience it on
Glass so that you know what
it feels like and you
know that it works.
For example, you wouldn't
want to read an entire
news story on Glass.
When we think about Glass, we
don't think about staring at
the screen all day.
Again, it's not directly
in front of my eyes.
We think about these
quick interactions.
So what is a good experience
is reading a headline or
seeing a picture coming out
there from the world and
getting these headlines
throughout my day--
those short, quick
interactions,
whenever I want them.
The next thing is that you don't
want to get in the way.
Glass users expect the
technology to be there for
them when they want it and out
of the way when they don't.
You want to make sure that your
service supports this by
not being too frequent and loud
with notifications and
provide appropriate controls
for the user experience.
And most of all, you don't
want to take precedence.
You don't want to override
or require.
If the user misses a
notification, it should be OK.
And an example here is that you
wouldn't want to do any
motile dialogues, for our UX
friends out there, with Glass.
If the user misses the
notification and doesn't
respond, it should decay
quietly and easily and
silently and the user should
keep getting notifications
like usual.
And the reason is they're
wearing Glass
throughout their day.
And when they're doing
something, let them do something.
They'll get back to Glass
when they want.
Keep it timely.
When you think about it, your
laptop or your desktop
computer, you work with data
that's maybe over the course
of the last few months
or year.
When you're working on your
phone, you can really think
about that as sort of
the day or the week.
Glass is a very right
now device.
So when you deliver data to the
user, you want to do it in
the moment and keep it up to
date, especially, like the A+,
is if it matters to them for
what they're doing right now.
And a real time notification
system is provided, right--
those subscriptions
that we saw.
So when you get those
notifications, you'll want to
respond right away and provide
that user with the experience
that they're expecting,
which is right there
with them, right now.
An example here is that you
wouldn't want somebody to send
a timeline card to you about
an email from a week ago.
You probably already saw that.
You want the email that happened
just now and happens
to also be important.
Then finally, avoid the
unexpected, especially the
unexpected and unpleasant.
You want to be transparent to
the user and give them the
functionality that they expect,
because unexpected
functionality is typically bad
on any platform, but it's
especially bad when it's on
Glass because the user is
wearing Glass.
An example here is if I signed
up to be able to share images
with your service but you end
up sending me timeline cards
about all your wonderful new
features every day, that will
be a bad experience.
You would want to use a
traditional channel like email
or something like that to let me
know what's happening with
the service and on Glass, I just
want that interaction.
So those are the
big guidelines.
Let me just highlight them one
more time on the screen here.
You want to design for Glass,
specifically for the Glass
experience.
You don't want to
get in the way--
we provide an experience for
the user that's there when
they want it.
You want to keep it timely--
make sure it's up to date and
matters to them in the moment.
You want to avoid the
unexpected-- you want to keep
away from anything that's going
to jar them or shock
them out of their life.
So we've been working with a few
friends to test this new
API and how these
new experiences
fit into our lives.
You've got to play with it and
use it and see how it works.
I'd like to share with you just
a taste of what we've
been playing with lately.
Does that sound like fun?
I'm going to keep
asking you these
questions this whole time.
Does that sound like fun?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
First, let's start with "The
New York Times." Now as you
know, "The New York Times" is
a leading global multimedia
information company.
It enhances society by creating
and collecting and
distributing high quality
news and information.
And if you're like me, that
means you sit down every
Sunday morning and
read the "Times."
But I also want news throughout
my day during the
work week, but I don't really
ever have the time to sit down
and read a newspaper.
What really works for me and
what we found is a great
experience on Glass is getting
headlines throughout the day
that are there whenever
I look for them.
And that's what we built.
Let's take a look at what
that looks like.
So here is a bundle of news that
I got from "The New York
Times" right before
I got up on stage.
It's an article about
the Harlem Shake.
And you'll notice it has the
curl in the upper right hand
corner there, that fold.
If I tap on this item, I get a
bundle of all these different
headlines and rich images.
And if I tap on any one of
these, I can get a card option
for read aloud.
So this is really great
for me, actually,
because I can hear it.
Uh huh.
OK.
The cool thing about that is
that I typically wouldn't do
that in front of an audience--
listen to a news article-- but
I thought it would be fun.
But I would do that when I'm
walking in between meetings or
I'm going for a short walk to
take a break, because then I
can kind of look at the world
around me and I'm also hearing
something about what's
going on in the
greater world that me.
So let's take a look at
the detail flow there.
What "The New York Times" is
doing is they're inserting a
timeline card.
In fact, they're inserting
several timeline cards and
they're setting a few
properties in there.
They're using the rich HTML so
that it displays with these
beautiful photos
and headlines.
They're creating the speakable
text, which is a little bit
different than I see
on the screen.
What they're giving me is a
summary of the story, so I can
see the headline if I want and
I can have the whole summary
read aloud to me.
And they're adding the Read
Aloud card option, so that I
can actually choose
to hear it.
And finally, they're setting the
bundle ID on each of these
so that every hour--
which is what we've been
playing with--
I get a new bundle
of news items.
And the cool experience here is
that as I'm going about my
day, I might see that this comes
in and take a look at
the news right there.
Or maybe I'm waiting at the
bus stop and I can see the
latest articles.
So let's go through the
guidelines one by one.
There's four of them,
remember.
First, design for Glass.
What's cool about this is it's
simple, it's there when I want
it, and I'm able to have this
read aloud to me so I can go
about my day.
It doesn't get in the way.
If at any point I miss one of
these bundles, that's fine.
The world keeps generating
news-- that doesn't stop--
so I can just see
the next one.
It's up to date with
fresh data.
So "The New York Times" is
really great about publishing
that news throughout the day
as it becomes relevant and
then delivering to me every
hour the top news stories
right then.
And then finally, avoiding
the unexpected.
And this is really easy--
I'm getting the news that
I expect regularly.
In fact, we're trying out this
other flow that's really great
as well where you get
breaking news.
And that just can happen
right away, and I get a
notification.
And with Glass, using the head
gestures, I can just look up
and I can see that
breaking news.
And "The New York Times" is
already really great about
delivering breaking news to
users when it's relevant, when
it's actually breaking and
important, and otherwise just
putting it into the
news cycle.
OK, let's do another--
my favorite email
service, Gmail.
Let's try this demo again.
So far it's worked good.
I'm going to go ahead
and tap here.
And it looks like I got an email
just a moment ago from
Jenny, my colleague back
in Mountain View.
Unfortunately, she couldn't be
here today, but we've got game
night this Saturday and I'm
going to kick her butt.
Let me just go ahead and
reply to this email,
if you don't mind.
Are you kidding?
I can't wait.
Smiley face.
And it's going to send
that message to her.
What it went into was a voice
dictation mode there.
I started a little bit too
early-- that's why it had that
"remind" word.
But then it heard what I said as
I said it, showed it to me,
had the option to cancel that if
I wanted to, but I didn't.
It went ahead and sent it and
she'll get an email that has
the text of what I just said
as well as the audio file.
So let's look at this in a
little bit more detail again.
So this flow starts when I
authorize Gmail to insert
timeline cards on my Glass.
Remember that OAuth process
that I told you about?
Again, this is really
sort of the install
process for Glass services.
I go over to the Gmail website
and I say, I want you to send
the most important emails
as they happen to Glass.
And it jumps into the OAuth
flow, I give permission, it
calls back to Gmail,
and it's done.
But at that moment, Gmail
does a quick thing.
It inserts a subscription for
all updates on my timeline.
Remember we talked about
subscriptions?
Essentially, it's subscribing
to everything I do on the
timeline that concerns it.
OK, so now we fast forward
to I'm getting my emails
throughout the day.
It inserts timeline cards.
And on those timeline cards, it
includes just some simple
text and a creator-- in
this case, Jenny--
and some speakable text
so that I can have it
read aloud to me.
It includes those card options
for Reply and Read Aloud.
And when I get that email as
a user, I tap on Reply.
Glass goes into voice dictation,
records what I say,
and then it notifies Gmail's
subscription endpoint.
Remember, it subscribed
and then it sends the
notifications.
The lightweight notification
just includes some JSON
specifying the timeline
item that has all that
text that I just said.
Gmail will then retrieve that
item, download the audio,
compose an email, and
send it to Jenny.
Again, very simple flow, all
cloud based, something that
you could build and do a first
version of in just a day.
Let's go through
the guidelines.
First off, design for Glass.
It's a simple, quick
interaction, and it's easy to
do while on the go.
It doesn't get in the way.
And this is really key for Gmail
is that I'm not getting
every email message that
comes into my inbox.
I wouldn't want that.
But I do get the important ones,
and Gmail is already
good at figuring out which ones
those are and sends just
those to my Glass.
And it's, of course, fresh.
I get the new messages
as they come in.
It's very timely.
And it avoids the unexpected.
I get emails and I send replies
whenever I want.
It's just a simple flow.
All right.
Let's do a couple more.
The next one is Evernote.
So Evernote, as you know, is a
family of apps that help you
remember everything, communicate
effectively, and
really just get things done.
In this case, I'm going to be
talking about two of them--
Evernote itself and Skitch.
Who here is familiar
with Skitch?
A lot of you.
I think Skitch is great.
It's just a really quick way
to take an image or a
screenshot and mark it up with
text and arrows so that I can
communicate how I feel about
something, whether it's a UI
design or architecture
planning, whatever
it happens to be.
The interesting thing about
Skitch, though, is that I find
myself, if I'm in a meeting
and I take a photo of
something that we're talking
about, I don't want to sort of
Skitch it up right then.
Why?
Because I'm in the meeting and,
like, we're talking and
we're communicating
about next steps.
Rather, I'd like to be able to
quickly give feedback at the
right time.
So let's try that, shall we?
So I'm going to swipe over to
the picture I took of y'all
and I'm going to tap.
I get my card options there.
I'm going to tap on Share, and
I'm going to swipe to Skitch
and I'm gong to tap on Skitch.
Now what's happened here is that
Skitch was just notified
that I took an image and
I shared it with it.
And again, how that happens is
I tap on the card option as
Skitch had previously inserted
a subscription and said, I
want you notify me at this point
whenever the user hits
the share entity.
So I hit that share entity.
It goes up to Google, Google
bounces that down to Skitch,
and then Skitch then takes that
information, downloads
the image, and sends an Android
notification to my
tablet, which is right here.
I can't believe I'm screen
sharing multiple devices in
this demo-- it's cool.
And this is Skitch.
It just opens up with
that image.
I'm going to go ahead and
buzz out my friends from
Engadget over here.
Oh, I'm just kidding--
I love you guys.
And let's go ahead and
say awesome press.
That's cool, right?
So these would, in any
other case, be my
notes during a meeting.
I'm going to go ahead and hit
Done here and save it.
And Skitch right now, as it
usually does, is going to
upload this into Evernote so
it's a note that I can access
whenever I want.
Now what I like about this flow
and how I've started to
use it in my daily life is
that I end up at these
meetings getting caught between
feedback and paying attention.
I can pay attention and with
Glass I can easily take photos
as things happen.
And then as I'm walking back to
my desk or going for a walk
later, I just share that with
Skitch on my tablet and I can
mark it up and save
it to Evernote.
And as you can see, there it
is right there in Evernote.
I've also got some Skitches
about fish and this talk,
because that's what this talk
needs is some more fish.
All right.
Let's go back to the
presentation here and go
through that again in detail.
So starting with the OAuth flow
again, when I authorize
Evernote to do things on my
behalf, right afterwards it
inserts a share target for
Skitch, or a share entity, and
it adds a subscription
for timeline updates.
Later, I take a picture.
I choose to share
it with Skitch.
Google then notifies Skitch
there's an update.
Skitch pushes that to
one of my devices.
I mark it up, save to Evernote,
and that's my day.
And the guidelines-- let's
go through each of
those, one at a time.
This one will go quick, though,
because it's really simple.
You design for Glass.
Again, being able to take a
picture without interrupting
what I'm doing and then be able
to take notes on that
picture whenever I want
is a very cool
interaction for Glass.
And it doesn't get in the way
because I can use the share
target whenever I want.
And as far as being timely and
avoiding the unexpected, I'm
making this happen by choosing
that share entity.
So really, I, as the user,
I am in control
of this whole flow.
All right.
Should we do one more?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
So who here is familiar
with Path?
Great.
So Path, for those of you that
didn't raise your hand, is a
smart journal.
It lets you share your life
with those you love and do
photos, thoughts, more
stuff than that.
But one of my favorites is
simply adding an emoticon to a
friend's post when
it comes in.
I can look at my Path timeline
throughout the day--
the path, if you will.
And as I see pictures that my
friends have shared, I can tap
on them and hit like Smile
or Frown or Love.
And I do this all the time
because it's a quick way I can
interact with them and yet
still go about my day.
This is a really great
experience on Glass.
So let's go ahead and see.
Oh, I got a timeline card right
at the front there that
I took a photo.
This is a demo device,
so that's why
there's multiple mes.
Anyway, this is really
an excellent photo.
I know, I took it.
I'm going to go ahead and tap on
it, and I get card options
for all of these emoticons.
And in fact, all the way at
the end, I also have the
ability to reply, which will
add a comment to this post.
Again, super simple, quick
interaction that I can do
while I'm going about my day.
I'm going to choose on Smile.
And that's done.
Path is going to get that
notification and it's going
add a smile from this demo
account to that photo.
Let's look at that flow.
Let's start one more time
at the OAuth portion.
I as a user go to Path and
I say, I want you to
send stuff to Glass.
I give permission, and then
Path immediately inserts a
subscription to timeline
updates.
Then, as I'm going about the
rest of my day or the week or
the whatever, Path is sending
me pictures from the people
that I know really well,
the people that I love.
And I can tap on any one of
these as they come in and I
can add a comment or I can
choose one of those emoticons
without really even breaking
my stride.
Now, the design guidelines
are pretty clear as well.
And we've been over these
a lot of times.
Let me do them one more time.
Design for Glass.
Love the way emoticons
work on Path.
It's just that quick
interaction.
It's a really great experience
on Glass because I hardly even
have to take a moment beyond
appreciating that photo and
being able to tell my friends
how I feel about it.
It doesn't get in the way.
I get these pictures as
my friends take them.
And because it's Path, they're
only people that
I know really well.
It's very timely.
I just get the pictures
as they come in.
And it's never really
unexpected.
This is the community that I've
already curated on Path,
and I'm getting the photos
that I love.
I'm just getting them
on Glass now.
So those were the demos.
Let me say one more quick
thing to kind of
pull this all together.
And this really calls back,
again, to those glass bars,
that feeling of the developer
community coming together and
wanting to do something together
on this new form of
technology.
We looked at all of these
things in detail.
The demo--
I gave you a quick look
at the Glass UI.
And we talked about
the Mirror API.
Remember, the four major
components were timeline
cards, menu options on those
timeline cards, share entities
to be able to share images and
video, and subscriptions to
get updates about both those
timeline card options and the
share entities.
And we looked deeply at each of
these guidelines that we've
been discovering as we've
been building these new
experiences for Glass.
There was designing for Glass,
making sure the experience
makes sense for a Glass user.
Not getting in the way, making
sure that the experience
you're giving your user makes
sense for them right then at
that moment.
Being timely or staying
up to date--
making sure that what you give
the user and how you respond
to them is in the moment.
It's right now.
And avoiding the unexpected,
especially the unexpected and
the unpleasant.
You want to make sure that the
user is getting the experience
they signed up for, and you give
them the right settings
so they can adjust it for them,
like being able to turn
it off on the weekend or
when they go to sleep.
And finally, we looked
at some examples.
And this is just where we
started, with a few friends to
test out the API in
its early stages.
And that's the thing.
This is where we're starting.
You've got to remember--
and I'll leave you with
this thought--
that Glass is in
early days yet.
We're really just getting
started, and the reason we're
talking about this today, the
reason we want to start having
this conversation, is that every
time we say something
and you guys respond with your
dreams and your visions for
using this new technology, it's
such a huge inspiration
to us, and it really affects the
work that we do on Glass
day to day.
So please, keep that coming.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]